you know we like to see redemption
stories i'm curious to know what you're
going to say since you're in this space
redemption stories robert downey jr goes
away for a few years he comes back he
crushes it
and we love that story you see it in
sports a guy goes away he comes back
he does very well for himself
you you you think a mancia has a shot of
redeeming himself in the comedy world is
it too late for him
gosh i think with mencia like i think
from what i've heard i i haven't run
into him from what i've heard he's doing
fine in the clubs and he's got his fans
the thing about comedy is
you can i mean if you get if you get
burned in the industry it's hard to come
back depending on what it was is it
pretty political or no is it a it's it's
political but it's also like what it was
so robert downey jr had addiction
problems and he comes back and people
are rooting for him they're like oh we
want you to do better right but if you
if you get caught for plagiarizing or
stealing
unless
and i'm talking about in the industry
now unless he were to come back and say
i want to make a movie about a guy
who lost everything because he got
caught plagiarizing and then he grows
and he comes back and you know he
realizes he's going to be himself or he
does a one-man show about fabrication
you know
something yeah southern but also like
showing that there's growth i mean maybe
then
um but the good thing about being a
comedian or a performer that tours is
your fans
love you i mean you're going to lose
some fans because of that but you're
still going to have some hardcore fans i
mean mencia is still a great performer
he gives a great show so i'm sure that
he's doing great on the road i don't
know about the redemption in the
business per se simply because of what i
just said unless if they come up with i
mean listen it's hard enough to make it
in this business without having to have
redemption because you know i've been
doing this 23 years i've sold like three
or four different shows and this and
that but it's never gone to the you know
to tell you know on on air because it's
hard to make it now
much worse if i had done something that
had a black check mark against me
and now i want to come back i almost
feel like you gotta address that thing
in your comeback yeah i you know kevin
hart and i were but you know when when
he came out with the responsible tour i
had him out as well i think i had him
out the year after you or two years
after you had them i don't know what it
was but were you 2017 when you came out
and you performed
i did 2017 2017 i remember we were
talking off air the thing about when you
came out which was
special is the week before your
performance i remember we got a call and
you know your your sister uh passed away
right which was right we and we were
having a conversation my guy's like pat
this is what i said whatever maz wants
to do
maz gets to tell us what he wants to do
it's his choice and you still chose to
come
and people walked everybody knew but
within the first two three five minutes
everybody knew and i said like this
guy's a one a pro but it was
great to see you come up there and do
what you do with the audience i remember
when that whole thing took place with
you but we brought heart a year later or
maybe two years later
and he did the irresponsible tour and he
kind of went up there and he talked but
listen first time i messed up i'm glad i
messed up
but the second time i messed up i really
messed up you know he went up just said
this is what i did that's what i did
and you're saying take a page out of
kevin hart's playbook to see if you even
stand the chance to make a comeback
yeah i think you need to address the
elephant in the room right so if i for
example
of whatever got caught for embezzling
money
and i did i mean richard pryor is a
great example richard pryor
set himself on fire trying to smoke
crack
and then he went on stage later
and did an act where he talked about
setting himself on fire and he made it
funny because he goes you'll never run
faster than when fire's chasing you and
it's on your back and whatever he did
you have to address it you have to
address it somehow either either in a
funny way or in a sincere way you could
go up if i had embezzled money let's say
i were bernie madoff and now i've gotten
out i'm doing stand-up i better have
some jokes about it or i better go on
stage and go look guys thank you for
coming out i appreciate you giving me a
second chance i embezzled all that money
and you know i i i don't know what god
and whatever it is i apologize my time
you have to address it because if you go
on stage and you don't address it
then uh uh you know no one's gonna
people are just gonna be thinking about
it the whole that makes sense i mean you
know we'll see what happened there when
we had him on i told him i said why
don't you reach out to rogan over the
internet twitter send him a tweet and so
once you guys get together he never
ended up doing it but uh who knows
what's gonna happen there but it is what
we wish every one of these guys nothing
but the best and hopefully they'll he'll
redeem himself so if you like this sort
of short club from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you